[Music]
buh-buh-buh-buh-buh welcome to we are
biscuits
I'm link and I'm Rhett this week at the
roundtable of dim lighting we are taking
your call we're doing that again yes we
are it's gonna be well we're doing it
again we don't know how often we're
gonna do it but we are doing it again we
had a good time doing it and many of you
said that you wanted to hear it again
and so we will be settling disputes
again we ask people to open helping some
mythical beasts yes people with some
conflict who are having some kind of
conflict with a friend or a spouse or
just somebody in their life slash Slavs
you know what they're doing the smart
thing they're doing the right thing
they're coming to us to solve something
that is potentially tearing at the
foundations of their relationship and
I'm coming to two dudes who just
happened to have an Internet show well
look at us but hey no don't sell us
short we freaking we freaking been
friends for a long time and that is not
without our fair share of conflict right
we know embrace they're not a work
through conflict we we've each remained
in wedlock with a person with a wife for
18 years 17 years 18 years yeah and may
27th was my anniversary six years
together combined yeah it's like it's
like I'm just trying to make it sound
like more than it actually is a 56 plus
the length of our friendship let's add
all those years together that's a lot
well how many years have we known each
other okay well I mean to see six plus
30 17 and 18 together is 35 and then
we've known each other since we were six
and now that's nine more T so that is 34
plus 35 69 years I read that earlier
yeah yeah so with a combined conflict
resolution experience of 69 years we're
taking your calls today
really
should have been a different number but
you know sometimes just just the way
yeah the math work that math works out
you know it's a universal language
before we get into your calls I would
like to link update you and new mythical
beasts listening on a new development in
my life
I mean I'm personally excited about it I
got new golf clubs is I mean last week
I'm when we talk about aging I didn't
mention something about you getting into
golf but listen getting into golf again
you did clarify earlier you said in the
last episode getting back into golf
because I did this is not again
I'm always accused of having phases but
I insist that they are layers because I
grew up playing golf I was on the golf
team at Hornet Central High School and
and your North Carolina now is there a
bench you just dropped the words from
your teabag into what is it saying what
is your tea say to you today what is
there a fortune on it yeah there's like
an inspirational statement I didn't know
that speak to make yourself happy don't
speak to impress others yes that's the
last thing that this man either hit me
to do here at the top of a podcast okay
um sorry guys but this was just for me
yes so what what the impetus for the
okay so I've had golf clubs for I got
golf clubs that were already a little
bit old when I was in college so I'm
guessing that they are 25 years old and
I don't play very often it takes a lot
of time I don't play with my kids
you don't play my wife doesn't play so I
don't have a lot of incentive to play
golf because it is quite a time
commitment and also in Los Angeles if
you want to go play on the weekend which
is the time that I have you are dealing
with a bunch of numbnuts out there
holding you up and it's just it's gonna
take you five hours to play so unless
you have new clubs I mean what add to
that the fact that my
back has been significantly compromised
in recent years with my disk issues but
I'm back on so you've had lots of
reasons to not play golf but you're
you've you've dug down to that layer and
then when you got there it seems to me
you discovered that there's lots of new
developments so much as change that's
justified but hurt us but the reason I'm
back is to buy things just well yes is
because my dad is coming into town
and I would he deeply loves to play golf
he plays all the time and I was like I
want to play with him out here in Los
Angeles and also if I don't have time to
go and actually go to the course and
play a full round going and just
knocking some balls around at the range
as they say and knock some steam off no
one has said that what is the what is
the blow some steam off below and blow
off some steam by knocking some balls
around I can do that it's not such a big
time commitment and I also think that
may be something I can do I'm a boys
anyway all that to say that I go into
the golf shop I went to this place that
like has like a swing fit machine this
is the way it works now I think it's
worked that way for several years now at
least maybe a decade or more where you
go into a simulator and there's a video
screen and are you talking about EA
Sports
Tiger Woods golf on Xbox well they
didn't put electrodes all over my body
and then model me for a video game if
that's what you're asking
did you know I'm asking did you play a
video game no they give you a golf club
and a real golf ball and a mat and you
literally go into light it was in a
strip mall you you hit a real ball a
real golf ball into a net but there are
machines around you that are measuring
everything and then projecting what the
ball flight would be if you were out on
a golf course and measuring all this
stuff about the launch angle in the
swing speed and and the number of rotate
spins and everything you know basically
a full analysis of your golf swing to
help you understand for they use it in
instructional ways but they also use it
when they're trying to fit you with the
new set of golf clubs
I freaking felt like robe
if Robocop was a golfer which by the way
that would be a good movie
Robo golfer yeah what a missed
opportunity
back when Robocop and Caddyshack were
both popular born at the wrong time as I
always say corporate what are they when
you drop when you're dropping the ball
what is that called when you get a drop
you get a drop you get a drop yeah
drop it drop it because that's what
heroes a cop says what he says Robert
remember that time that we went to see
our Hollywood agent and we went into the
it was a high-rise building in Beverly
Hills and in the bottom there's big
glass doors and you walk in there and
there's a fitness center down there in
the lobby and Robocop was going into
fitness center yeah turns out he's just
a regular man he's an actor yeah the
actor who played Robocop right and I
leaned over to you and I was like drop
it
no I leaned over and I said yeah that
was there I remember there's a moment
for me anyway those people aren't our
agents anymore I go through Efrain
agents I go through the process man I'm
like I'm hitting I'm hitting real balls
on a fake golf course future is here in
1918 in order to to sell you fully
customized golf clubs yeah I mean
basically I was like I haven't spent any
money on golf in two-and-a-half decades
and you about to make up for I'm going
for it all the way from the top of the
to the bottom of the back so I got a
driver a 3-wood I went with a hybrid for
the three and the four iron didn't ask
and then I went from five to the
pitching wedge and then I got myself a
sandwich which I've never actually had a
sandwich never had a sandwich no I had
one at one point I waited I was just
like I'm just gonna do the pitching
wedge with that for everything it's kind
of kind of a hack and I got me a ping
putter I got a new putter not a sponsor
not a sponsor and then and then I also
got like a sand wedge that looked like a
sandwich
you know like sandwich down at the end
of the pole it's got a little sand what
they called a shaft this
shaft mother there's what they call it
at the tip of the shaft there's a
sandwich the end of the shaft is
probably there's a sandwich yeah that
probably won't be effective well it's
just painted on brother
I got myself a wolf pack bag an NC State
red and what's red and black because you
don't want written red and white are the
official colors but you don't want a
white bag because you get it dirty
so you're embracing losing with whoever
you play evil people are going to think
that I'm like hey did you play well you
play college golf until they see me
swing they are I mean you are did you
think about that because you you are
gonna get a lot of that a lot of that ah
did you did you did you play college
golf yeah is it your bag I play golf in
college yeah I play golf in college a
few times and not for the college team
that's not lying
yeah I play golf in college hey this guy
played golf in college college golf at
golfing college or do different things
that's you asked me that I play golf in
college I will just say yes and let you
believe whatever you want to believe I
wouldn't ask you that I'm not gonna be
there but I didn't stop with the clubs
you may notice that again not a sponsor
but I'm wary I have made that I've made
the turn I've got an Apple watch yeah
I'm one of those guys you can hate me or
love me I don't know I just got the
thing what now I understand it I mean I
want you to I want you to have your fun
man and I want I want I don't you don't
need to justify any how you spend your
money to me well I'm not justice but I
don't and I understand that if one is to
play golf one should have golf clubs
yep and I'm not gonna nitpick like if
you're gonna get bottom top or middle of
the line golf clubs but you've top of
the line but but but oh no you got a
what you got an Apple watch but because
you're playing golf
well there were a lot of factors
conspiring over the past couple of years
for me to get an Apple watch I love the
idea of having a Smart Watch I was
always a little bit afraid of what it
might say about me and you know I feel
like if you don't have a watch nobody
judges you at all or anything but if you
do have an Apple watch people people
judge it clearly
that you played golf in college yeah but
having a SmartWatch says something about
you that maybe negative in some people's
minds but what I let's just come out
with it what does it say I mean I don't
I don't have anything in mind it she's
got money to burn
he's money Peggy no it's just he's he's
techie but in a little geeky little like
Becky and like a looking down your note
like an elitist he's a tech elitist with
too much money on his hands well I
didn't say that I'm just I mean you
don't have to be rich to have an Apple
watch I mean but I I just think it says
something about like maybe you're a geek
maybe you know more maybe this guy can
fix my computer no I can't fix it oh
that you know I'm saying I don't make
any assumptions about me here's why I
got it I've wanted one for a while one
of the SmartWatch I like the idea of
having the ability to communicate with
something like Dick Tracy and I also
like the fitness features because I am a
man that likes to work out I like to
measure things like my heart rate and
how many times I stand up and all that
stuff and your iPhone can do some of
that but not all the data tracking we've
talked about on previous episodes yeah a
lot of that kind of it's one step
towards being a transhuman you know you
got to have a SmartWatch somewhere along
the line let me say two things first of
all I don't love the way it looks I mean
I've never been this close to someone
with an Apple watch that I could just
say exactly what I thought I can now
they're preparing you're wearing it I
can get a different band if you want me
to I'm I pretty much I don't like the
way it looks well I didn't get it
because of a fashion statement what
don't you like about it though I don't
it's it's it looks bland I can make this
I can put anything on the screen it's
all black and it's a little - it's so
sleek it looks like a it looks like a
like a stock watch that then you would
that got rejected from the factory
processes before the cool stuff was done
to it well that can be changed all that
can be changed if I could figure out how
to do it I would change it like if it I
I guess I'm thinking like a tag
you were if it looked like one of those
freaking watches in like a magazine well
I think first of all I can change the
face to make it look like a wino so
because we're talking about the form
factor brother the but the band can be
leather I can get I can get this to be
brown leather but then I think you
wanted you sweat into it you I had a
long conversation will Ross if it looked
like if you look like a diver like a
diver's watch or like a survivalist
watch like something a little more
rugged well I had a conversation with
rocky to the Apple Store and he talked
me it back into just start small just
you know start in this you don't draw
too much attention if I have some fancy
watch now everybody's looking at it then
noticing is an Apple watch and then I'm
getting extra judgment at this point
it's just like Apple watch geek freak
whatever you want to think yeah it's
yeah it's over it's not least not a
trend anymore but your real question is
why did golf going to play golf lead to
me getting Apple watch well because it
was hell on earth 'you justifying this
purchase yes so i was like okay i know
that there's a lot of technology now
with the gps and like you can use your
phone while you're playing to know
exactly where you're at on the course
because all these golf courses are
loaded into these golf apps and so now
you can get to a place and be like i am
exactly 167 yards from the front of the
green and the pin is in the back and
these are the wind conditions like golf
apps have all this stuff on them and
then i'm reading about these golf apps
getting ready for my to play with my dad
okay and then it's like oh if you have
the Apple watch you don't have to take
your phone out you can track all your
shots and do all your data entry look at
that the weather just see that I'm
tapping it and I know that it's 65
degrees you don't have that just so you
know I didn't care to know that it's 65
degrees outside right now okay it's
warmer in here I can't tell you how warm
it is in here I don't have that
technology well if you keep this up I'm
gonna go out there and experience it and
also I have the ability to there's an
app that tracks the swing like because
it's got an accelerometer on my hand I
can track my swing and measure the swing
plane in the swing speed that's a little
more compelling than I was I don't want
to take my phone out of my pocket in but
while I'm golfing because it's such a
such a difficult sport what's more
annoying having a guy fumble for his
phone in between every shot when you're
trying to play with him and get back in
the cart and suffer does having a guy
indiscriminately or discreetly look down
and sort of like I'll tell you what's in
this Apple watch you asked what's
annoying we're sitting in our office and
we're having an intense creative
conversation or we're in a meeting with
some other people and every time I look
over at you you're looking you're
looking at your phone Dick Tracy
I mean you mean watch oh yeah it's a
watch I mean it technically is a phone
with my wife on it you're looking at
your watch
and it's freaking annoying and it it
feels insulting because it feels to me
like you're looking at the time I don't
I know you're probably looking at SLAC
or an email or how cold it is outside
I'm also in the honeymoon phase with my
watch my just looking at I'm looking at
you're not looking at what's on the
screen you're just looking at the watch
no I'm measuring things but it's it's
the thing that nobody does anymore when
it's like all right it's funny how when
you want to get out of a conversation or
any situation you might find yourself
looking at your watch in order to like
signify I'd like to check out of this
predicament
yes 2018 those days are over there but
but I still interpret your body language
that way and it's insulting and annoying
you're gonna have to get used to it the
resting heart rate right now is when I
turn and look at you I want you looking
at me and engaged in whatever we're
doing 73 beats per minute however I'm
gonna start looking down at my wrists
that's because I'm a little bit elevated
I'm passionate about this but my resting
heart rate on average today was 59 beats
per minute just that's that's just me in
my life
my walking average today when I was
walking it was 69 69 again we can't get
away from that number and the this
morning when I was on the elliptical
no one asked for this it was about 135
beats per minute and then in my recovery
it was between 131 and 101 I will say
that if you do decide to get like a more
of a rugged diver esque version I'll ask
for that I'll take that one
no no I'm gonna just take the band I got
to keep the main part man the watch part
yeah I got the cheap one - I got the
aluminum I didn't even go stainless
steel I mean I
you know wait I'm trying to show off to
anybody if you're done with it I'm just
saying how I use it and last but not
least I got a dry fit polo shirt to play
golf in and you ought to see me in that
thing I do where can we see that Rhett
just go all the way well I mean I will
be taking a picture of myself and
posting it on my Instagram shout out to
red MC on Instagram where you can find
all great pictures of golfing Rhett when
they happen but right now we just want
to give a shout out to our own store
exactly because we're not selling an
Apple watch but we're selling lots of
stuff
I mean don't sleep on mythical dot store
because we add stuff all the time and
for the summer we've got the good
mythical summer camp t-shirt again
there's no actual camp but there is a
shirt which might lead people that look
at your shirt to believe that you went
to a camp with us where we were your
counselors or your friends or your cooks
the links got on the the beautiful not a
sponsor shirt right there because we say
that a lot I am wearing the Apple watch
not sold not sold a mythical dot store
but this is the the Friends logo
inspired mythical t-shirt that's a
popular item a little nineties blend
thank you for supporting entertainment
and wrapping us when you go around
conversation starter hey it's a way to
let people know that you're with us and
we're with you and they should watch to
thank you Fraenkel dot store let's take
our first call let's resolve a conflict
hello who are you and where are you
we're from lol st. Louis John and a man
doesn't Lily well welcome to ear
biscuits guys thanks for calling them
how can we help you
so a company caught the conflict that my
wasn't I have or she's always
complaining that I have too many shirts
you know combination of polos and
t-shirts and she's always lying meet you
either get rid of some of my shirts for
you know not have as many shirts or that
every time I get a new shirt she's like
oh another shirt so yeah how many shirts
are we talking about so in preparation I
counted yeah so I have 29 t-shirts and
20 polos hmm 49 shirts
Wow so you can almost make it two months
and you're you're fine with this but
Amanda let's hear your side of this well
I feel like every time I do laundry at
Groundhog Day
because there's you know half of the
shirts are in one load of laundry and I
caught him in the past
triple layering me shirts and it's just
you know washing the Sam shirt over and
over again
and I I I just feel it's just so
draining to just go through this it's
like running a marathon but with shirt
hmm did you say he sometimes triple
layers t-shirts and cold weather yes
John have you heard of a sweatshirt like
a shirt and then I'll do a t-shirt maybe
another t-shirt then a polo then a
sweater it's really cold right hmm I'm
trying to figure out how the number of
t-shirts impacts the amount of laundry
you have to do because my my snap
judgment is is that it's independent
right but actually the more shirts you
have the less you should have to do
laundry because you can let it build up
more because you have more shirts to go
that are still clean you're not
necessitating washing shirts you can go
longer and do bigger loads no I think
you'd become more indiscriminate when
you've got a bunch of t-shirts because
then you're like I can just I got more
to wear I'm just gonna put this one in
the dirty clothes washing clean clothes
that's bad because the the bottleneck on
the the washing is the capacity of the
washing machine and the capacity of the
people who operate said washing machine
how often they wash it they operate it
but I think I have some insight into
this because serendipitously I just went
through all my shirts I also went
through my went through my pants but
this isn't about pants this is a certain
about pants let's stay on topic keep it
above the belt so what what what did
what why did you go through your shirts
and then what was the conclusion I went
through my shirts John because I had too
many t-shirts and I didn't have to have
my wife telling me that my own heart
told me that because what I did why what
what is you cuz you know I'm a t-shirt
guy
I mean I'll wear a t-shirt there's
limited capacity and I have a t-shirt
drawer and then I have a shirt section
of the closet where I hang shirts and I
hang about 5 to 7 t-shirts that are that
I don't have to worry about them being
wrinkled in there a little bit what I
would call nicer t-shirts oh yeah and
then I've got the the drawer full of
t-shirts which are more like gonna throw
something on I gotta go work out I'm
going camping whatever yeah and it was
becoming difficult to fit all the
t-shirts in the drawer and it was
becoming difficult to fit other clothes
in the shirt section of the closet so I
went through all of them and my process
was taking a shirt trying it on
full-length mirror checking myself out
that was fun and then making a decision
very quickly if that shirt made me feel
uncomfortable in any way I put it into
the thrift store pile and I did that and
I and I and I was you know I was pretty
you had
made me feel real good to be kept and I
got rid of a number of shirts and I
ended up with a drawer full of shirts
that has capacity for a few more shirts
if I see something I really like and
then an easy-to-navigate closet I think
I'm down to about 15 t-shirts and you
know about 10 or 15 polos and there's
more stuff here at the at the office I
mean I
but laundry was not a factor in your
decision
no because laundry is done on just when
the hampers fill up in my house so it
doesn't matter how many shirts you it's
more a question of access what I learned
is that by getting rid of t-shirts I was
making better t-shirt choices and I was
also like oh I've got that t-shirt oh
that's a cool t-shirt but it was covered
up by t-shirts that I've been rejecting
and haven't been able to get down to the
t-shirt that I actually would accept to
my body yeah you know I've got a lot of
t-shirts here at the office that I can
just if I need to slam on another
t-shirt for whatever reason I can do
that but definitely at home but I got
two drawers for t-shirts I got like a
black and grey drawer and then I've got
a colored t-shirt drawer no exciting and
then I've got and I don't and then my my
shirts are in the closet but I got
limited amount of space and I absolutely
agree with you that you got it's it's
dictated by your storage space at least
for me now if you're not doing your own
laundry John then you got to defer to
the person who's willing to help you
with your laundry so if Amanda
is taking issue and if there's again I
think there's some holes in her logic
but I think in terms of like more
t-shirts generating more laundry unless
you're being wasteful and putting clean
stuff in there but I think all that
secondary to the fact that if she's the
one doing that a lot more than you you
kind of got to defer to her unless you
want to start doing more of the laundry
and I think that's what I would you know
I think I think she's got the she's got
the power play in this and I think you
could benefit from
from from gleaning a little bit get just
just hone it down to the ones that are
most special and then for the ones that
are super special like I got a couple of
super super special t-shirts that have
like nostalgia those go in a special
places framed that you just know that
those are off-limits
and if you if you acquiesced Amanda a
little bit then I think the risk of you
losing your most special t-shirts in a
in a fit of laundry rage which happens
to everybody you know you could you you
don't want to risk destroying some of
your some of your prized old t-shirts
like the one that I slept in for 25
years yeah still sleeping that's not
normal alright I kept every t-shirt from
me playing recreation soccer as a kid a
little weird but cool they they say
Buies Creek and they have my number on
the back from every year and you know
what Lando sleeps in those every night
it's real sweet and it makes me feel
nostalgic yeah and it's a super soft
t-shirt everybody wins but you got to
give a little in order to get those
special moments with those t-shirts that
linger around so I say what is the
number whatever Amanda says what do you
guys think about that
George was a huge issue we we actually
just bought a whole nother dresser so
it's been a little bit better since that
and your point about the laundry I do
completely agree a lot of times to try
and avoid this disagreement I will try
and help fold and do laundry sometimes
but it's it's in anticipation of
avoiding the conflicts to begin with and
being helpful
Johnna I will just say that Rhett wasn't
listening to your response because he
was looking at his phone I mean he was
looking at his watch yeah I got an I got
a new Apple watch I'm just ready but he
is looking at his watch a line I keep
calling it a phone I I didn't hear
anything in your retort John that makes
me think you can't get rid of some
t-shirts as just a just an act of
goodwill I'm seeing an olive branch
out of 29 t-shirts I'd say just start
with seven just call seven and see what
happens okay well I addressed I
addressed it you gotta set those got it
you got it you're most sentimental
t-shirts they're a different category
don't get rid you know so you got some
tough decisions to make
but I think I think it'll it'll it'll
pay dividends in your relationship and I
don't know but buying another piece of
furniture might it might have been a
mistake yes so thanks for your call guys
and good luck with that
thank you you're welcome
okay let's take another one resolve that
one who are you where are you all right
where are you guys at California oh
right at the road birthplace of Merle
Haggard have you been to the birthplace
no we're talking about Merle Haggard
Buck Owens wasn't born there I know that
he he helped create the Bakersfield
sound either he lived there and all that
but no he's not the special one to us
we're fans of both though but how can we
help you okay well it seemed short and
simple at first but uh this is is it
better to be in hot weather or cold
weather okay mm-hmm and what do what are
what are your opinions on this
well I strongly believe that hot weather
is better and I believe cold weather is
better by a long shot
and do you do you find yourself having
to decide that you're gonna move to
colder weather because Bakersfield gets
really hot but it's more of a
hypothetical situation that you would
you just want us to kind of weigh in on
who's right which we can of course do
and also you can think of it like in a
survival situation
uh like if you're in if you're stranded
in the wilderness it's what do you have
a better chance of surviving if it's
hotter if it's cold I think then if you
think about it that way you can actually
find the real answer oh really
okay Oh see Maddie's making our argument
I get it yeah
well Mason do you do you have do you
have a quick argument before we give you
the right answer in the winter but like
in the heat like you can keep taking
clothes off like there's a limit okay
true this is a classic question and in
most of time it doesn't really come up
as an argument it comes up as someone's
like I'd rather be if they're really hot
they're like I don't really be cold with
any day if they're really color I'd
really be really hot any day
it's ass is always greener in it and I
do if you're talking about survival
situations I mean at some point on both
ends of the extreme you're gonna die
right if it gets too hot for too long
you're gonna die if it gets too cold
even if you put a bunch of clothes on
you are eventually gonna die if you if
you're an extreme cold you're gonna die
but if you're an extreme hot as long as
you stay hydrated
you're not gonna die if you assume that
you have water and clothes even with a
lot of clothes you're ultimately gonna
die like you said but with water I don't
think you are so that's the factor if
we're talking about the normal range of
temperatures on earth and civilized put
in civilized areas is that what you're
kind of getting at yeah so I don't know
I think we probably both agree that like
we prefer both we don't like being cold
so we prefer being hot so like if you're
saying which one is better like I'd
rather be really really hot if we're
talking about normal temperature ranges
then really really cold just personal
preference yeah however with what I've
been reading about from you know the
guru wim HOF and this whole idea that
when you're really cold you actually
begin to activate your brown fat stores
so you've got brown fat and white fat
brown fat is something that we linked
this makes links nice basically
I'm talking about brown fat Hagee he
gets very sneezy
okay you got another one not yet
you start talking to have another sneeze
so brown fat is something that is it is
something our ancestors used to remain
warm and extreme cold temperatures but
now that we have such regulated
environments when it comes to
temperature air-conditioned environments
we have very very little brown fat but
huh well the thing that wim HOF does it
would the whole Iceman wim HOF method is
he builds up the dis brown fat so where
does the brown fat reside it's not like
white fat which is like you know in your
belly in places like this higher back on
top brown fat shows up in like MRI scans
like in your neck and your gun your
spine and that kind of thing and it
actually begins to burn the white
activates the white fat to begin to burn
to generate heat so if you have it so
it's not like you look fat it's it's
it's it's not it doesn't have like a
bulk to it the cool thing about it is is
if you build up your brown fat stores
you actually help your immunity I
haven't read all I haven't read all
about this but basically it's better for
you just as a human to have that the
durability that comes with having more
brown fat so while my preference is to
be warm as is mine it would actually be
better so if you said which one's better
it would be better physically and like
holistically to be colder than it would
be to be hotter and there you have it
Mason so good luck with that thanks for
calling breaking out the wim HOF science
write me that's good i I don't know if
we I helped it's not about helping us
about being right okay and they made
they may die trying but at least they're
working on the brown fat work on that
brown fat let's take another call
hello hey it's rhett and Link who are
you and where are you hi my name is
Shelley and I am in Jacksonville Florida
and then my roommate who is just walking
into the room now I'm Lindsey hello
Shelley and Lindsey how does it feel to
have just walked in the room Lindsey did
you know that you were you were going to
be part of this your biscuit
conversation Shelley when she found out
she was very very excited alright so
what is your issue so our issue is about
a backpack recently I asked Lindsay to
get my wallet out of my backpack and I
told her it was in the back pocket and
she came back and said that it was not
in the back pocket and so she made me
panic so I went to the backpack and I
checked the back pocket and it was in
there and so I came back to her and I
was like the back pocket had my wallet
where were you looking and she said
that's not the back pocket so then that
led to a discussion about what is front
and what is back on a backpack what is
the front of a back this is a juicy one
yes I have had this this argument before
okay so not with me though no we have
this I don't think we've ever talked
about this you've argued with someone
else about this okay so just to just to
clarify so Shelley which okay if you're
wearing a backpack the pocket that is
the furthest from you the person you
consider that the front of the bag how I
consider it oh gosh your cat your cat
owners all right I have to got a
recalibrate okay all right here it's a
balance are they both going in the back
so okay so the straps for me the pocket
closest to the straps would be the back
pocket the pocket farthest from the
straps would be the front pocket and
Lindsay finds it to be the opposite okay
it is first of all let me I'll have my
answer that it is that it is inherently
confusing I have a logic okay well let's
just say what what what we think I think
that the pocket furthest away from the
person wearing the backpack in the very
back of the backpack is the front to the
back pocket the back pocket because when
you look at a backpack the the part that
everybody sees is the front and so the
front just most part is the front pocket
that's the front of the backpack that's
part that everybody sees because if you
were to hang a backpack on a on us on a
rack in a store so as to decide to
potentially purchase said backpack you
want to look at the front of it yeah
yeah I think that's why it's called the
front cuz it's the part that you look at
okay I on a backpack I'm sympathetic to
this logic okay and back is the part
nobody ever sees it the back goes
against the human back which is just
coincidence I'm going to see I'm going
to steal man your argument so I'm
actually going to add to your argument
before I break it down okay okay
you see I going a straw man you're gonna
steal man my argument steal me that what
straw like straw man steel man steel may
have heard that steel man is when you
correctly and generously state your
opponent's argument okay I'm glad you
warned me that though you're about to
agree with me it's only ultimately to
disagree right I get it so if I wouldn't
take it if I were to see backpacks for
sale not even in a store but just like
on a website they would show me what you
consider to be the front of the backpack
like innocent in the same way that they
would show you like the front of a
t-shirt usually the front thing is what
you would face to evaluate whether or
not you were gonna purchase said thing
and that is why this is
errantly confusing however when a
backpack is on a person it is oriented
in a way I think it becomes a part of
that person and then everything is in
reference to the person who's wearing
the backpack because if you wear a
jacket you say the front of the jacket
is the front of the person the back of
the jacket is the back of the person and
so every end that the front of a hat is
the thing that's on the front of the
person the back of the Hat is on the
back of the person every other article
of clothing is evaluated in reference to
the human anatomy and a backpack is for
a human's back and so to remain
consistent with that logic the front and
the back line up in the same way and
then when you begin to move when a
person begins to move forward the
backpack is moving towards its front
which is the strap side it's it's
difficult because when you take the
backpack off of a person and you
evaluate the backpack on its own it is
logical to assume that what I would call
the back is now the front but the
backpack is only a backpack when it's on
someone's back I am going to steal man
your steal man argument and say that
that that that is that's a brilliant
perspective that I 100% agree with
accept ok when it's not on the back it's
still a backpack so you think it flips
it flips depending on whether somebody's
wearing it or not that is the scenario
that they presented to us she what she
said will you go and get my wallet out
of the front of my backpack implying
that it wasn't on her person I'm certain
of that but we do have to come to some
kind of agreement well we could come to
the agreement that it changes depending
on if it's on the backpack or not oh
well ok if it's on the back of the
person I wrecked listen by the way what
if sometimes I wear a backpack on the
front of my person in order to if I've
been wearing it all day like in an
amusement park full of water bottles at
that point it becomes a large fanny pack
which is a totally different thing
hmm okay so so you are wearing the
backpack and like when I wear the
backpack at an amusement park and I ask
my sister to get something out of it it
is now in front of her
it is still on my back it is in front of
her which pocket then would be the front
versus the back well my argument is that
it should always be even when it's not
on a person I think we have to have a
convention that we stick with and maybe
this is just a regional thing like every
family every group of friends agrees on
what it is because it is inherently
confusing because it feels different
when it's on somebody but to me when I
look at a backpack I evaluate it in its
functional capacity which is on
someone's back and so that's why I
consider the back of the backpack to be
the farthest thing from me the person
and so in my family that's what we call
the back pocket is that little pocket in
the way in the way back first of all I
would never call the big pocket like the
biggest area of the backpack that's the
front block I wouldn't call it a pocket
I witness a main compartment say the big
I would say the big okay I would call it
a [ __ ] I would call it the big pocket
you could label you could to get a label
ER and label each pocket just a number
system and just be like get it out of
pocket number one if it was on me okay I
you know I'm trying to be impartial it
doesn't matter if I have to change my
answer or even it's because your
argument or not I'm just saying all
right I got the backpack on like can you
get can you get something can you grab
my keys out of my backpack which pocket
the the outermost pocket I mean I think
that's what I would say I've never said
I've never wrestled with this issue
personally because I've never said the
back pocket I'd be like I will leave the
lower park I'd be like the little pocket
in the back that's not not the not the
little the smallest pocket that's like
straight across but the bigger pocket
that's a little it's still not the
biggest yeah that's a cumbersome
conversation so so I don't know we're a
little bit of a stalemate here I don't
know what we've done for you but I kind
of feel like you guys either need a
labeling system or you just need some
sort of
compromise to just agree not you can't
compromise somebody has to win this
argument so maybe you flip a coin and
then this is how you refer to it or
Lindsey you just know when Shelley says
back that she means front and vice-versa
and you just keep that straight in your
mind it'll probably make new neurons
grow if you do that I mean this the
thing was Lindsey this was your
opportunity to rummage through every
pocket of her backpack who knows what
you could have found you know you were
to decide well you looked in one pocket
and gave up I think the real issue here
is that you lack determination resolve
and are you even a true friend
yep she you are trustworthy she sent you
to get the wallet she thought I think
Shelley thought you stole the wallet
okay
did we help I don't think so but good
luck with that thank you you're welcome
back pocket I guess I'll go with
backpack it's a tough workout you know
what it's a tough one man you know I
just a little pocket big pocket little
pocket I would just use different
terminology let's take another call
hello hey you got rhett and Link who are
you and where are you I'm Morgan and I'm
Jordan and we are from Staunton Virginia
the big VA that's right does it in VA
yeah yeah what are you guys dealing with
what are you disagreeing about well
we're having a disagreement about
whether or not it's okay to make
comments during movie okay let me hear
let me hear you to your sides to this
okay so I think that it's okay to make
comments during the movie and of course
these aren't like random comments there
are comments about the actual movie and
what's going on but Jordan I I believe
that you should just sit there and enjoy
the movie in like
enjoy the movie and any disruptive
comments are gonna they're gonna break
the immersion Morgan what what type of
things are you are you talking about
that you that can't wait um I don't know
just something that like just happened
that's so crazy or something that if
it's like a sequel to another movie if
it ties in with something that happened
in the last one and now it all makes
sense or sometimes I do have questions
especially if it's a movie that Jordan
has seen before and I don't completely
understand
hmm okay okay Morgan I'm going to I'm
gonna put this as nicely as possible
you are objectively and definitively
wrong yeah you're not you're not gonna
get any sympathy from us because we are
we are movie movie noise Nazis around
here oh yeah I mean I've told this story
before of during the Hobbit movie I
think that was the movie when you know I
went with the kids and then like these
people were talking to making fun of the
movie and yeah there were I think there
the criticism might have been valid but
it was so distracting and I turned
around and I was just so angry and it
just came out I was just like shut the
hell up and and then I was so afraid
that they were fans the RET I've never
I've never cursed it any stranger ever
except in this instance and you know
I've slept on it I reflected on it and I
stand by it in front of my kids like
they were they were just like so that
might be a little extreme but okay but
to Jordan's point here now first of all
I'll get upset with my family if I'm
showing them not a movie but like one of
my videos sometimes I have to like force
my family to watch what I do for a
living and sometimes they get the
reaction you wanted to process it yeah
in a minute like not there's a lot
happen but sometimes I'll just I'll look
or Belize
face while she's watching one of my
videos and she's like looking at her
nails or something like she's high like
she's looking at it but then she's like
she's distracted she's like looking I'm
like look at the frickin screen like
I'll lose it and she's talking it's even
worse and and again I'm trying to get
her to watch something that's mine but
if we're sitting down watching a movie
it's like in the McLaughlin household
all the lights are off oh I got you
nobody speaks everything is in place if
someone has to get up to use the
restroom there is a pause I cannot eat
while watching anything because we are
also artists Morgan and I when when
somebody crafts whatever it is that
you're watching if it's worth watching
every second has been crafted it would
be assumption that you're gonna be
looking at it and listening to it and
not talking over it or being distracted
by someone else talking over you know
that that one moment that that you're
glancing over to hear what Morgan sane
Jordan you might be missing the most
important thing you know and exactly and
and in some some of the time you don't
have to say that Jordan we're wet we're
winning the argument you just sits idly
by and just let it happen
[Laughter]
you know it's crafted in a way to be
watched and processed silently however
there are exceptions and Morgan I think
this is where you can have a little fun
and this is when you are watching a
movie nostalgic ly watching a movie for
a second or a third time watching a
comedic movie or a horror movie and a
group of friends I believe that the
rules change so I think that now I can
get a little annoying sometimes if
people are too too into this thing but
like I'll watch a horror movie with
friends it's something I like to do
occasionally for like a birthday
celebration and some buddies and people
talking just makes it fun but like if
I'm watching a movie for the first time
and I'm and I'm really into it you know
and I want it to get everything that it
offers then there's no time
[ __ ] unless there's like an emergency
if like somebody's like you know choking
and usually at that point they can't
speak so it is usually choked you know
Morgan I think complete a win-win I
think I can't turn again Jordan you just
need to keep quiet Morgan
trust me Morgan I think this is an
opportunity for you to just to turn over
a new leaf
you know it's um save your questions
till the end and and a lot of times
questions that are being raised in your
mind while watching a movie are
intentional and they're about to be and
they're about to be answered in that oh
gosh I hate have an answer questions
that you're not supposed to know the
answer to yet so just believe if you
don't if Christie asks me something one
of the kids you're not supposed to know
yet that's why you're at that's why the
questions going through your mind that's
the beauty of that was intentional yeah
I'm sorry Morgan I know we're we're for
dramatic effect we're being a little
mean to you act and actually then also
being Mina Georgia just but please
forgive us for that we're we're you you
you touched a nerve
yes but we're also just giving you a
hard time
ultimately you guys got to come up with
a system and maybe there's a compromise
that does involve with home viewing some
sort of Jordan you might maybe give her
an X number of pauses an intermission
maybe there's an intermission you got
any questions I'm sorry Morgan
that might work you know that's true
yeah okay but in my defense when I'm
making comments about a movie usually
it's a movie that he has chosen to show
me or this even happens of music that he
has like made because he's a musician
also I'll comment and try to show that
I'm interested in what's happening
because that's my way of showing it and
it just makes him angry right yeah I
mean if Jordan's auditioning his latest
hot lit track for your ears you know I
think you just
you know if if he wants you to take it
all in just wait just wait to the end
you know you might need a notepad take a
few notes that's a good idea but not a
phone an actual notepad that doesn't
light up because that's a whole
different issue phones in the theater
okay well we we hope we have helped at
least somewhat we like link said we feel
pretty strongly about this but good luck
with that did we come on too strong I
mean I don't I think there are sometimes
but sometimes you have to yeah you just
gotta you know when someone's that wrong
yeah you have to be that right okay
let's take another call actually we are
going to just read this question okay we
wanted to prioritize an international
call but we had a little technical
difficulty with the international call
but just so you know we we heard your
cut a lot of people said you guys are
just taking calls from the United States
but we're not we were taking one from
Poland but it's 3 a.m. there and there's
been some technical difficulties so he
also commented her her question yes all
right so this is from Adriana and her
partner James she says we keep arguing
about the proper way to load up a
dishwasher ok
or more specifically about cereal bowls
placement top versus bottom rack oh now
this is okay yeah this is definitely a
litmus test of of of living together is
what you do with that dishwasher no and
also it's a good personality test and I
would figure I I well I would go as far
as to virtually guarantee that you have
a formed opinion about dishwasher
loading like any time absolutely any
time like there's any moving like any
time that I've ever moved with link into
or out of something he is if you if he
isn't the guy who's placing the things
inside the moving truck he's so anxious
to be the guy that's placing things
inside the moving truck that you better
just let him do it otherwise you're
gonna be dealing with a very unsettled
man
I mean there's so much a stick with a
dishwasher because a it's a puzzle I
mean you you and you want to maximize
the amount of stuff that goes in there
because you know what's gonna happen
anything that doesn't get in there
before you close that thing up and you
start washing it anything left behind
you you you technically need to go ahead
and wash so that you can have a clean
slate or even if there's an if it all
fits and you've succeeded oh boy if you
don't empty it quick that that that sink
is gonna load up especially when you got
three kids running around and a dog and
a dog throwing dishes in there yeah so I
consider it my life's mission whenever I
open that dishwasher to optimize it
again to a fault you know we talk about
our personalities and this every
strengths can become a weakness you know
the amount of time I spend rearranging
the dishwasher rearranging from what
everyone else in my house has done oh
really oh it's just that's nice it's a
bit much but it's it feels so good to
get it right I mean I'm gonna get to
cereal bowls but I mean for starters all
those utensil cubbies down there on the
bottom at least in my dishwasher I mean
in an ideal world it would be it would
be sorted by type so when they're clean
you take the whole caddy out you take it
over to the drawer and then you can just
grab a section of grab all the forks at
once and slam them in so you grab all
the spoons at once that makes you and
you don't do that you don't sort it by
type I do that yes but you're saying
that your family doesn't follow that
they don't really do that and I also put
the sharpest things at the back so that
due to your knives up
I do the knives down from safety right
and I'll put them at the back also so
that's two reasons why no one's gonna
get cut namely me and then I put like
the baby spoons at the front because I
just feel like there's no risk with the
baby spoon Oh risk but with bigger
spoons I don't know what the risk is but
really a little bit of risk so they're a
little bit further back so
there's actually way too much going in
thought going into this but it feels
good when it happens that way I don't I
don't rearrange all the utensils if it's
like slam full I just say I just let it
was at that point you're not saving any
time but I also have this when it comes
to the top rack that's clearly meant for
a things that can't go on the bottom
rack when there's certain type of
plastics that you don't want down there
it'll be too much too close to the
heating element and it will damage them
right you got to put them on the top and
then after that you got to put all your
cups up there because that's usually
that's where they're designed to go it's
always a pet peeve of mine when I open
it up and someone didn't start they just
threw a cup kind of in the middle so you
got to start the cup at the far back
left corner and then and then work
against that and then building a tight
cohesive puzzle of dishes and then at
the bottom rack you've clearly got what
the designers the the the dishwasher God
has dictated is the place for plates
right and not only is it the place for
plates but it's the place for plates to
be facing a certain direction correct so
that they lean back and they don't they
don't touch each other all plates have
to be facing the same direction for them
all to be cleaned optimally and I found
myself turning around the plates all the
time you sound like you're explaining
it's important dishwashers to like
someone who has never seen him which I
again I know that lots of people don't
function correct but you know like the
diverse talk you get about like a new
piece of equipment and you kind of have
listen to it you know I know this is
what the manufacturer intends but I'm
just gonna kind of do my own thing but
you're but you're really breaking down
dishwasher etiquette anyway that would
make any manufacturer proud bowls are
the bane of my existence
balls are tough balls are bad I actually
you know I I tried for a while to eat
things that belong to bowls and other
things yes so I wouldn't have to put
them into
dishwasher if it's a in it you know
what's worse than a bowl because I'll
get back to a cereal bowl is a big ball
Oh big balls Christy oh I don't know how
between Lilly and Christy they'll they
go for the big bowls for things to like
mix and cook stuff yeah that typically
is rather used for them and then they'll
just put them in the bottom rack and a
bowl a bigger medium-sized Bowl will
obfuscate what could be a space to hold
eight plates it ruins everything and
then what are you doing you're basically
signing up to hand wash eight plates so
there are many many days that I will
open the dishwasher then with dirty
dishes in there and I'll see a two big
bowls and I'll take them out and I'll
I'll put them in the sink to hand wash
it and then I'll take the crap that's in
the sink and I'll I'll load it all in
dishwasher and I've reduced the amount
of time that I'm taking Washington
dishes cuz yeah heck yeah I washed lots
of dishes proud of it
but there's a right way to do it anyway
what do you do with the but then those
those ceará balls are freaking tough man
and with all the answers I have I'm now
to the point where I'm about to tell you
I don't fully know oh gosh it's a puzzle
you do everything else that I said and
then with the space remaining you load
it up starting with the smallest bowls
and then going up in size until the
dishwasher is full then what's left you
wash in the in the dishwasher so if
you're but isn't there a bowl section in
your dishwasher it's it's hard to say
there is there is what I have deemed to
be a bowl section and it is on the
bottom right so I do put the balls on
the bottom because you have a Bosch we
go through so many we have whirlpool not
a sponsor okay Bosch not a sponsor
either because that'd be weird they're
competing competing brands we could we
can have competing brands Foster's and
we could just go at it to you by bar can
we do that can we get let's lower a bar
shirt like to race car drivers on the
Bosch man world oh man
for commercial Kings but when we were
shooting that show we we wanted to do an
ad for a mattress store because they
have a lot of local commercials but we
what we decided that we wanted to do an
episode where we took a whole block of
mattress stores and make a commercial
for the whole block so it's like come to
our block and we were gonna bring
together all these different mattress
store owners and proprietors so many
next to each other to cut the other
always together and bring them together
in the same commercial we thought that
would be cool and Buzz worthy it was a
great idea I couldn't get him to agree
no one would agree to it but that was
their loss well okay let me you know I
don't have nearly as strong of an
opinion about this but I will say what
well okay my final answer is the the
bottom and if you if you've loaded bowls
earlier you may have to take them out
you just got to be willing to do that
and then if for some reason when you're
ready to wash there's room on the top
and there's no room on the bottom you
put bowls wherever you can get that
dishwasher as full as box then where you
fit in yeah that's my official answer
it's more of an order of operations
thing than it is one correct answer I
think this all applies also in Poland
yeah I believe Poland is the same the
what you you the most compelling thing
you said in terms of the way I approach
this personally because I'm not gonna
rearrange anything like if people have
done something wrong I'm just like screw
it I'll just get the rest of this right
I just put the things in the place that
I have interpreted to be the
manufacturers intentions yeah you know
what I mean and I and I again I've
interpreted it to be a book there's a
bowl section there's not a boat there's
not one in mind okay you need a flaw you
need a boss man a sponsor my boss I'm
not but I will be because of the bowl
section I think I will be too and you
know and they're all up in a nice angle
and they're almost touching but not
touching it sometimes I wondered how mr.
Bosch figured out how but is to get the
the water streams up into there and but
the concavity of the ball is is slightly
downward facing a little bit yeah cuz
it's the bowl section because you don't
want to open a clean dishwasher and have
a pool of water oh and definitely big
balls have no place big balls are not
allowed big balls are hand washed
everytime complete agreement the problem
in my house is people putting things in
the dishwasher that have no business
being in the dishwasher like a garlic
press like it you know in America you
know things that okay a garlic press is
always and only ever going to have
garlic on it rinse it you just rinse it
you know what it is garlic is already
antiviral antibacterial it's gonna smell
like garlic the next time you use it
it's just gonna be up troublesome little
gadget to put in there so when you see
it in there you take it out no I just I
just complain vocally loudly I said
don't put the garlic press in the Bosch
I refer to it as the Bosch you don't you
thought it was funny that you you're now
deciding to do that because you just
have amused I will because you thought
that was so funny
I'm gonna hold you to that I will from
now on you butter and also you're not
supposed to put knives sharp knives
should not be in the dishwasher because
water is bad for your the sharpness of
your knives in fact as soon as you get
through using a knife you should rinse
it and dry it because it is an oxidant
oxidation process like a rusty it's but
it's more subtle than you think
you gotta have dry knives that was my
nickname in high school
dry knives I was I was so about nepo
nose dry knives in the Bosch that
everybody was like let's just calling
that but you don't do that you do not
write when you use a sharp knife yes I
do
I wash it and dry it I I am I wash other
people's knives in my house if I see a
knife I wash it dry it put it back where
it belong in the block my in-laws do not
use the dishwasher they've never used
their dishwasher it makes me so angry
because when I'm at their house
and they're hand washing dishes all of
them with a dishwasher right there have
you had a conversation I said gently why
don't we why don't we load the
dishwasher is it a Bosch
it's a Bosch and they're like well it's
one of those things where you don't get
an answer because the answer is we don't
use the dishwasher there is no answer
they built that home for themselves why
is there not why do they have a
dishwasher I don't know for I don't know
for emergencies you know for emergencies
I don't know what the psychology of it
is it it's something about I don't know
it must be like some sort of perceived
energy efficiency or something I'd I I
could not get an answer out of them and
I'm in no position to argue it's like
when I go to their house I'm just trying
to keep everybody happy so they only
have detergent I mean you couldn't mean
their guy they've got hand washing
detergent but they don't have isn't it
different I don't know and a squash and
and you know what Christie's sister does
it she hand washes too I think they hand
washed it they don't use their
dishwasher I think I have to think they
use it some if you had a marriage your
wife she could she maybe I don't know
what the reason is it's a glorious
device now you want it to be full for
efficiency sake but then it's so
efficient I mean what we load up that
dishwasher and we're still constantly
washing dishes I mean we spend when we
eat dinner as a family after dinner we
all go in there we're washing dishes
we're trying to clean up it takes
freaking an hour it takes three times as
long to clean up as it does to actually
eat in my home that's because it's a
whirlpool let's plate that's not not
that and I'm talking about all the hand
washing that we have to do in addition
to loading the freaking dishwasher right
well we just we just throw everything in
the Bosch with food on it we need two
dishwashers part of the strengthen I
think when you have five people in a
home and you're eating like a double
wide like a double fridge you get a
double dish I I'm legitimately thinking
it I'm gonna add a Bosch beside my
whirlpool so side-by-side comparison
and I have a bowl only dishwasher Oh the
bowl Bosh the ball Bosh Bosh four bowls
that's a good idea
call me wash so Adriana and James her
partner good luck with that I don't know
if we helped but as you can see we he
got me worked up he definitely I was
having so much fun until the end of this
and now I'm freaking you're gonna go
wash dishes
why am I so angry out sudden so mad okay
well this is fun this is fun for me
personally I'm gonna I was having a
great time until I don't know I didn't I
didn't mean to bring I and here's the
thing my brother-in-law he listens and
he I'm gonna get a text oh yeah you're
okay JB just go ahead and text me but
can you explain I mean why you don't use
you your dishwasher I mean is it just
because our in-laws because they're his
in-laws too
yeah that's how it works don't use is it
is there some sort of like legacy thing
going on here it's like it's a wonderful
thing the dishwasher you know it's it's
a man I mean I don't I know you know
what it is I'm not I don't have to tell
you but I am curious why you're not
using I think you do use it's um it's
not like but but the in-laws I don't
know maybe we can get through to him
okay okay all tournament personal
message his also know that Bobby's VCR
died so he's looking for a new one
instead of a DVD player yeah okay yeah
all right yeah good luck with that I was
just so angry
[Music]